So yesterday I didn't have a chance to get
to this.
But I do want to play this clip for you.
Donald Trump has launched yet another attack
on elements of plumbing, including showerheads
and dishwashers.
And this has been a really bizarre obsession
for Donald Trump.
Here he is a few days ago talking about, I
guess, how Democrats don't want you to have
reasonable water pressure.
Democrats, I guess, as far as Trump can, Trump
is concerned, want very Beda showers, whereas
Trump wants powerful alpha showers with high
water pressure or something.
See if you can understand what Trump is talking
about here.
This is lower than that, where bringing back
consumer choice and home appliances so that
you can buy washers and dryers, shower heads
and faucets.
So showerheads, you take a shower, the water
doesn't come out.
You want to wash your hands, the waters as
you come out.
So what do you do?
You just stand there longer.
You take a shower longer because my hair I
don't know about you, but has to be perfect.
Perfect.
Dishwasher's you didn't have any water, so
you were the people that do the dishes, you
press it and it goes again and you do it again
and again.
So you might as well give them the water because
you'll end up using less water.
So we made it.
So dishwashers now have a lot more water.
And in many places, in most places of the
country, water is not a problem.
They don't know what to do with it.
It's called rain.
They don't have a problem.
And old fashioned incandescent light bulbs.
I brought them back.
They have two nice qualities, they're cheaper
and they're better.
They look better.
They make you look so much better.
That's important to all of us.
But they're better and much cheaper.
And they were mandated out.
Legislated out.
And we brought them back.
And they're selling like
hotcakes.
So this is like a completely outrageous rant.
I mean, these are truly the rantings of a
madman.
It's meaningless nonsense.
This is the type of stuff where, you know,
you see someone in the subway yelling about
this stuff.
You probably call crisis services and say
somebody seems to be having a mental health
incident right now.
And these are the things that Mike Pence sits
in the front row and nods along as if this
is normal to hear from a president of the
United States.
And this is not the only time that Donald
Trump did something like this back in December,
feels like years ago.
But it was December before we at least knew
that Corona virus was in the United States.
Trump ranted about light bulbs.
And remember him saying people are flushing
toilets 10 or 15 times.
Oil companies are very happy about that.
But together, we're defending the American
workers were using common sense.
We have a situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and other elements
of bathrooms where you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous amounts
of water, where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it and you
don't get any water.
You turn on the faucet.
You don't get any water.
They take a shower and the water comes dripping
out, crimping out very quietly, dripping out.
People are flushing toilets 10 times, 15 times,
as opposed to once they end up using more
water.
So EPA is looking at that very strongly at
my suggestion.
You go into a new building or a new house
or new home and they have standards only.
You don't get water.
You can you can't
wash your hands practically.
There's so little water comes out of the faucet
and the end result is you leave the faucet
on and it takes you much longer to wash your
hands.
You end up using the same amount of water.
So we're looking at very seriously at opening
up the standard.
And there may be some areas where we'll go
the other route, desert areas.
But for the most part, you have many states
where they have so much water that it comes
down as cold rain that they don't know.
They don't know what to do with it.
So it's really weird, like what is Trump doing
in the bathroom that he's flushing a toilet
10 or 15 times.
That's really strange.
And this is about something.
Right?
And it's actually about a few things.
First is this obsession Trump has not just
with toilet flushing, but rolling back regulations.
And the idea that the right has wanted to
frame up for a long time is there's so much
regulation.
Everybody is overburdened by regulations,
businesses, construction companies, consumers
that this bird and backbreaking burden of
government regulation from Obama.
Of course, there's you know, the water pressure's
too low.
You can't wash dishes.
You can't shower.
You can't properly use the toilet, apparently.
And so they want to frame regulation.
Happy Democrats under the Obama Biden administration
as passing too many regulations.
And Trump is unburdening us by canceling those
regulations.
Now, this is, of course, completely
crazy.
Like, everything's fine.
Water pressure is fine.
Dishwashers are working fine.
Everything's fine here in Boston and Massachusetts,
I should say.
We have some of the strictest building code
when it comes to efficiency and appliances.
I run my dishwasher one time.
It's a beautiful thing.
I flush my toilet one time.
It's fantastic.
I turn on a light bulb.
It's a, you know, CFL.
And I get all the light I need.
I'm able to read my books.
I'm able to read my magazines, all of this
different stuff.
Everything's working fine now.
And we have some of the strictest building
code in the country.
The sad thing is.
Trump is actually sort of tiptoeing around
an issue.
I would love to see a president make their
issue water quality.
Much of America has disastrous water quality
in some parts of the country.
You can't drink the tap
water in some parts of the country.
You can, but it's pretty vile. Flint, Michigan.
Obviously, the situation is worse than that.
And I would love it if we had a president
who said water quality is going to be my issue.
This is a serious issue.
You read about water quality at a global level.
You find out that there are so many deaths
just from lack of water that that is safe.
You have, you know, adults and children dying
from water quality related issues, parasitic
infections, diarrhea, cetera.
If we had a president listen, there's so many
things the president can focus on.
That's the truth.
If a president said, I'm going to do all of
these different things, but one thing that's
not getting enough attention is water quality
in the United States.
It's an issue of civil rights, isn't it's
an issue of economics.
It's
an issue of class and globally.
My goal is to reduce by half the number of
people that are getting sick and dying because
of lack of access to safe drinking water.
That would be such a material improvement
that a determined American president, as you
know, the so-called leader of the free world
most of the time could do.
And Trump is talking about water, but he's
talking about flushing toilets 15 times and
I guess low flow water heads or something
like that.
Trump really just making not make making little
sense during this event in general.
Here is Trump saying that there will soon
be announcements of things that nobody thought
possible or had even conceived of.
So we have many exciting things that we'll
be announcing over the next eight weeks, I
would say things that nobody has even contemplated,
thought about, thought possible and things
that we're going to get done.
And we have gotten done.
We've started in most cases.
But there's going to be a very exciting eight
weeks.
A. Eight weeks.
Right.
I think, Mike, we can honestly say nobody's
ever going to see eight weeks like we're going
to have.
Yeah.
They're going to announce things that no one
has even contemplated.
Crystal clear, right.
So something is very wrong here.
I don't know whether I would say the wheel
is spinning, but the hamster is dead.
I don't know if I would say because we're
talking about lighting and showerheads.
The lights are on, but nobody's home.
I don't know exactly what the right phrases,
but this is truly a man disconnected from
reality.
And I keep going back to 36, 38, 39 percent
of the country supports this.
There's a there's there's people out there
who see this and they say, yeah, that's what
I'm voting for.
I'm voting for this guy, ranting about light
bulbs and flushing toilets.
Millions, tens of millions of people will
be voting for what you just saw in November
for another four years of that.
And as I've said before, that's a
scary.
The Trump tests are scary as Trump.
And the reality is we will we will have Trump
ism for longer than Donald Trump is in office,
whether Trump leaves in January or January
of 2025.
Either way, Trump ism will outlast Trump.
And that's going to be a real problem we have
to deal with in this country for a long time
going forward.